[Music]
look what I become
okay so we have to go live because of
the announcement we just made a uh uh
what is it two hours ago three hours ago
when I was on Megan Kelly today at two
o'clock and there was a lot of people
asking questions we were gonna wait till
Thursday to go live and everybody said
let's go live tonight for 45 minutes
answer some questions on the offer we
just made if you haven't heard uh if you
want to pull this up Rob so we can talk
about it uh we made a public offer to
Tucker Carlson on the great Megan Kelly
show a few hours ago and then we tweeted
our offer and we put it out there it's
an article you can see the details it's
Crystal Clear uh two Tucker Carlson let
me start off by reading this if you can
zoom in a little bit more so the
audience can also see it this is you can
find us on Twitter dear Tucker I'll get
right to the point
we want you to partner with us in what
we feel is a noble and necessary effort
to define the future of media here's our
offer 100 million over five years and
equities taken by taemon president of
item and a board seat to project your
strategies your strategic vision and
voice your podcast plural singular and
other daily weekly shows documentaries
and movies covering topics you care
about what else we're all ears our
convictions about Freedom Liberty and
Truth Run Deep and we believe we are the
absolute right fit for you in America
why we may not be the biggest media
company
we are a new media leader driving into
the future to make truth Fair debate and
commentary more accessible consumable
and protected we are 100 serious about
our offer respectfully uh myself so that
message was sent out I gave that to
Megan Megan asked some incredible
questions going back and forth and we
got a few things that we want to talk
about today we got a handful of clips
that Rob's prepared I want to share with
you about what Tucker has said on why we
felt this was a an ideal uh offer to him
uh Tom you know I've been talking about
this with you since last week when we
heard about the news and then we
processed it more and then all of a
sudden this morning seven o'clock in the
morning I had a call with you guys and
we had an emergency call I said tell me
this is a bad idea okay and I kept going
at you going I said I don't want to stay
private I want to announce this publicly
because I think it needs to be something
everybody knows about and then the
announcement was made we agreed on the
podcast we were writing it and it made
the announcement to Megan what are your
thoughts about this announcement that we
made today well first of all I think
it's really important that that a lot of
things nowadays happen with transparency
we've gone through an era of covid and
other things for such a lack of
transparency I I think that transparency
in a lot of ways takes speculation out
of the mix and makes it certain and I
think that's what that's all we want to
do here is take the speculation out
whenever you start working together
there'll be always some peon at a law
firm that kind of leaks it's like you
look at uh professional sports contracts
Pat right all the people involved swear
that nobody said anything all it takes
is one Associated Law Firm leaking it
out and so I think what this is is an
open straight up transparent statement
so that people understand how serious
and how capable and more importantly how
important we feel our role is in the New
Media landscape
yeah you know it's it's pretty wild to
think about the era we're living in
because back in the days all of this
would have been quiet Hush Hush you
can't say anything what about this and
what about that well this person said
this and that person said and we think
they're saying this we think they're
saying that you have to be proactive
today and you know uh let the I think a
bigger part of an offer like this being
made as well is who he hears from from
personal friends so think about it you
know a a Tucker Carlson who is loved
adored by a lot of people and obviously
he is he's got the right enemies as well
whoever his enemies are if you don't
agree with the enemy's philosophies
guess what you guys are right enemies
right he's going to get messages and
people are going to say you know what
here's what I know about this brand and
by the way for the audience for those of
you that have helped valuetainment from
day one when we had 60 subscribers not
60 000 60 subscribers where we went from
there to a thousand to ten thousand to a
hundred thousand now we have total
whatever six million subscribers and now
turning it into a median company
Consulting from all these other things
that's happened pbd podcast the audience
with the members you know know all the
folks that we have with a a value Tema
and PVD podcast none of this would have
happened without you but I also think
this is a once in a lifetime type of a
guy I think his voice is super necessary
and our offer is a serious one and and
hopefully next steps will be uh going
through having different kind of
conversations a lot of people have
reached out guys my phone I am trying to
catch up on text messages I'm trying to
catch up on DMS I'm trying to catch up
on it's coming in hot and heavy yeah
it's all angles from all over the place
yeah go ahead it's just a it's a it's a
great thing it's a great movement Pat I
mean you're obviously serious about what
you're doing and I and everybody has to
play their part just like you know in
football yeah when like Tom Brady wants
to come to a team some people have to
take pay cuts on the team so that's why
I to make this thing happen
I took a 30 pay cut which what a noble
guy you are to make that hundred million
100 million dollars I'm all in Pat I'm
here that's why you're Vinnie I mean
that's why you're Vinnie and that's why
you're loved by everybody but so let's
do this Rob if you got if you got that
stuff ready let's just kind of go
through some of these things because
right now gang if you're watching this
you know everybody knows what some of
the offers are out there outside of what
some very powerful people that would
probably reach out but it's not like
people don't know the offers whether
it's you know Tom you've given the names
whether it's you know Newsmax whether
it's the the oans of the world whether
it's other Legacy whether it's the
rumbles of the world whether it's
Spotify whether it's you know some
billionaires saying let's come together
and start a media company together and
what if we do this and what if we do
there's so many different options of
where to go let's first talk about
frustrations that Tucker has shared in
different shows over the last few months
Rob if you can get a couple of these
things uh prepared for us to just kind
of go through okay and these are his
words so this first one here this is
what's he sharing on this one if he
can't zoom in because I can't see it
what's this one about Rob uh this one's
discussing you can't talk about yeah
building seven so this is one I mean
look you can't even talk about these
types of issues some people are
interested in it go ahead and press play
last thing I'll say is like it they're
not offended by craziness they're not
offended by conspiracy if you go on TV
tonight and say I think the Earth is
flat people just laugh at you they don't
care if you think the Earth is flat it's
not a threat to anyone
but if you say like
what what actually happened with
building seven like that is weird right
it doesn't like what is that right if
you were to say something like that on
television they'd flip out they would
flip out so you'd like lose your job
over that why why it's my country right
is it attack on Mike tree can I ask you
like I don't really understand do
buildings actually collab no they maybe
they do I don't know but like why can't
I ask questions about that anything
you're not allowed to ask questions
about
is something you should be asking more
questions about
it question
so so the issue right there okay
is he alone there is he the only person
that wants to know what happened to
building seven I I remember the podcast
we had with the gentleman that talked
about building 17. did they take it down
remember that yeah Richard Gage Richard
take it down I mean we went back of
course yeah we went back and forth he
said this he said that what about this
and what about that a lot of people have
questions on it some of it doesn't make
sense some of it doesn't add up you look
at the clips you look at the videos this
just doesn't add up guess what there's
got to be a place for a person like that
to be able to talk about that now
there's a couple different places you
can talk about that but there's formats
as well there's certain formats that you
can create where an audience can go find
what you have to say about your thoughts
on building seven yeah can I ask you a
question yeah how long until they
because he's talking about they we know
who they are so they figure out a way to
come after the the places like we are or
the news Masters or because Pat they're
trying yeah I'm just trying I'm curious
to how long you think today because
they're finding a little loophole to try
to come in to sound because this is this
is their biggest fear are these
conversations are those conversations
what do you think well I think we saw a
small proxy of that uh we're parlor and
remember I have a parlor there was some
intense pressure put on their hosting
partner now their hosting partner just
operates servers they buy electricity
they plug in servers they operate a
large infrastructure and that's where
parlor lived those weren't parlor
servers parlor was renting that space
and pressure was put on the
infrastructure the server people to say
you know what we don't want to do
business with you turn you off and so
there already is like a there's a big
chessboard Vinnie and there's pieces
that move around to try to shut off that
kind of conversation and and that I
looked at that and I was like wow isn't
that interesting you don't like what you
say maybe shut off your hosting so now
you have to go find hosting providers
and people that agree with you so it's
more than just maybe the producers say
hey we have a lot of Pharma advertising
on this channel so don't be screwing
around talking about the allergy meds or
Lord God vaccinations don't bring that
up these guys pay the bills they pay
your salary and their big advertisers so
knock it off it could be that simple
that's a very direct right that's Tit
for Tat you know very direct or it can
be indirect where they're like man we
don't like what these people saying
parlor is conservative they're getting a
little voice out here you got the
election going on man we get a you know
what let's put pressure on people to
shut their servers off so there's a lot
of ways out there and I think the
resistance needs New Media companies
that can stand up to that resistance and
find ways to stand in the middle of the
cloud and give that message to the
American people that want to hear it I
love it yeah I I agree Tom I don't think
that's going to be something a guy like
that should be able to talk about that
stuff and let us make a decision to say
you know what we don't agree we don't
think you're right we think you're right
let me go to my own due diligence let me
do a little bit of research myself Rob
do you have another clip you wanted to
show I do this was uh Tucker's uh he
appeared on the full send podcast where
he talked about Jeffrey Epstein being
murdered and the fact that Tucker
devoted an entire episode of his show to
Jeffrey Epstein being murdered and not
committing suicide and nobody now here
here's a here's another question how
many average Americans are sitting there
saying you're so concerned about
investigating what happened with uh what
he called it what happened with uh uh
what's the word with uh Stormy Daniels
with the 120 000 hash money why are you
so like this is so important we have to
figure out get to the bottom of this we
have to do this indict him indict him in
Manhattan yet a guy a a guy who's a
pedophile who has been proven to do what
he did Epstein you don't want to find
out and get to the bottom of that well
look a lot a lot of average Americans
think that's a red flag so play this
clip of Tucker talking about this we
know that he was murdered he was
murdered in the special housing unit of
federal Lockup in Manhattan
how do we know he was murdered oh wow
look into it dude we did a whole section
on my show nobody cared
um you should it's on it's beyond belief
and I'm very skeptical of any kind of
conspiracy theory or whatever why don't
more people go after this though we know
that he was murdered because well for
one thing I A friend of mine is one of
the people who last talked to him on the
phone the day he was killed what and he
had a expectation of a bail Hearing in
two days he thought he was getting out
he was not despondent at all I talked to
his lawyer told me the same thing
they moved someone out of his cell
they put two people one of whom was not
even a full-time prison guard on duty
none of the cameras trained on the cell
worked they were all out of it that
night
[Music]
they locked the front of the special
housing unit that had eight cells in it
but then they opened all the cells
inside
so who was it so I asked a really simple
question the Bureau of Prisons who were
the other so they're eight cells 16
minus his cell because he was alone so
that means there are 14 other inmates
there that night what are their names
where'd they go
some of them are transferred out right
after who were these big questions can't
tell you that really you can't tell me
that why on the basis of what because
some inmated a federal prisons privacy
concerns like Trump telling what are you
even talking about meanwhile the
Attorney General of the United States
under Trump Bill Barr issues a statement
being like no you know it's totally Bill
Barton lied there's no question that
bill Barr
basically clearly suspected Epstein was
murdered but stopped the investigation
into I went and read bill Barr's book in
which he explains all this and it's like
complete and transparent
so I have no idea why the attorney in
general in the United States would be
lying about this but there's literally
no question that he did I know him so we
Bill Barr's super nice guy
we reach out to Bill Barr like hey why
don't you come out and explain why you
lied about Jeffrey Epstein's death no
yeah wow by the way how many millions of
people I'm busy that day how many
millions of people tens of millions of
people you think would like to get that
question answered how many people um
I would say hundreds of millions
probably 100 million people if you're
thinking 300 330 million people United
States and even third would be 110
there's probably 110 Republicans like
know about that probably a hundred
million people would very much like to
know about that it's a fair question
that he's asking why don't we go
investigate that well that's called
journalism and a media company news
outlets should go investigate that you
cannot say a hundred percent this
happened that happened but let's
investigate and see what happened with
that what's this next one Robert so I
can say 100 that it's odd and deserves a
story there's no question I think it's
more than uh guys not to not to stop the
video it's more than uh it's we we're
not stupid we get it I mean it like he's
a threat bro Tucker's a threat that type
of conversation those questions they
don't want to hear because there's so
many people at higher levels involved
the only one guy that got kind of in
trouble was who Prince had prince prince
Andrew Pat you know what his punishment
was from the queen you can't have any uh
like gummy duties yeah you can't speak
in front of the public and what when you
hear somebody talk about these I don't
even want to call them taboo
conversations but these topics that
people have d team taboo like Jeffrey
Epstein like World Trade Center seven
you immediately pigeonhole them as
right-wing conspiracy theorist but this
is a video from 2019 ABC's uh Good
Morning America's Amy robach or roback I
remember this uh she just left the
network after she was involved in that
affair with another guy but this is a
video that she was captured on video off
Mike talking about how she had the
Jeffrey Epstein story and the network
made her on it for three years so
you could sit here and make the claim
well if you believe Jeffrey Epstein
killed himself you are was murdered then
you must be a right-wing conspiracy
theorist but then you look at this which
is a ABC for all uh all intents and
purposes yeah it's not a right wing or a
left-wing media outlet and this is what
she had to say about the investigation
that ABC made her not report on gosh
when the red light's on you're not
supposed to talk yeah shut up Amy can
you can you refresh that to see if it'll
clip because I know exactly what this
clip is and it's a great one just try
one more time to see if it'll happen
again so Tucker is not the only person
that's asking this question so are other
people this has got nothing to do with
left or right this is just people that
are curious go ahead I've had the story
for three years I've had this interview
with Virginia Roberts we would not put
it on the air
um first of all I was told who's Jeffrey
Epstein no one knows who that is this is
the stupid story
um then the palace found out that we had
her whole allegations about prince
Andrew and threatened us a million
different ways
um
we were so afraid we wouldn't be able to
interview Kate and will that we that
also quashed the story
and then
um and then Alan dershowitz was also
implicated in because of the plane so
she told me everything she had pictures
she had everything she was in hiding for
12 years we convinced her to come out we
convinced her to talk to us
um it was unbelievable what we had
Clinton we had everything
to get on to no avail and now it's all
coming out and it's like these new
Revelations and I freaking had all of it
I I'm so pissed right now like every day
I get more and more pissed because I'm
just like oh my God we it was um what
what we had ABC other women producers
are probably going nuts behind the
screens right now like what are you
saying ABCs
like who was Jeffrey Epstein what do you
mean who was Jeffrey Epstein meanwhile
she's not a freedom fighter she's just
saying damn it I lost a Pulitzer she
lost yeah because at the end of the day
it's good I'm not being overly spiritual
or religious it's good and evil and evil
right now is winning because you can't
even say it they're so protected it's
insane look at JFK pad how many years
ago was that they're still hiding
documents they're still saying no you
guys can't see this because we're not
we're not smart enough to figure it out
but we're not stupid we're just living
in a different era the difference
between 1964 you know when when you know
November 22nd when JFK assassination
happened and today there's one thing
that wasn't around back then there was
no social media there was no citizenship
technology there was no people just
getting out there and talking about what
they thought about it there was no
podcast and there was no let me tell you
what I think about this there was no
people that just got up and said I need
to get to the bottom of this it was just
Legacy Media that's the one thing you
had to take you have to listen to what
they had to say and that was it you
cannot do that today there's a lot of
people that are questioning so Tucker
saying this on Legacy who's been in it
with Fox for 14 years of saying listen
even me at a place like Fox can't really
talk about what I really want to talk
about sometimes and it was really
interesting about the Kennedy
assassination you just said the word
citizen journalism the Kennedy
assassination would have been a canned
story from the U.S government if it
wasn't for one citizen
standing
at the edge of the grassy knoll on a
piece of concrete with a small video
camera and his name is Adrian zephyrus
and if it wasn't for Adrian Zapruder the
you know Kennedy killed by Oswald the
whole thing would have gone there and
instead they started talking to other
people they had the zap Rooter film they
talked to other people but it was
citizen a little citizen who became
citizen journalism he was just he was
doing that for himself I'm gonna go down
and take pictures the president's gonna
be driving by he's got an early little
movie camera going to show his family oh
my gosh this is where I was and remember
for example they didn't release that
film once they had possession of it that
film was not released until 1975 when
Geraldo Rivera did a Good Morning
America at night special so that video
they knew was around for 12 years before
it was shown to the public wait frame
194 I wonder why here it comes I wonder
why I mean really I wonder why so
speaking of uh JFK Tucker devoted in an
episode to the JFK assassination and
this is a very interesting clip it's
only 27 seconds yeah of course
we spoke to someone who had access to
these still hidden CAA documents a
person who's deeply familiar with what
they contain
we asked this person directly did the
CIA have a hand in the murder of John F
Kennedy an American president and here's
the reply we received verbatim quote the
answer is yes
I believe they were involved it's a
whole different country from what we
thought it was it's all fake wow
I can't tell you how many people have
sat downward from the JFK side because
I've always been curious about what
happened here again this is the American
history we should know what's wrong with
digging in and wanting to know more the
fact that he's he is asking that
question and if you were to ask yourself
why does Joe Rogan kick major ass on
podcasts maybe because he asks questions
and thinks thoughts and has concerns
millions of others have why why does
Tucker Carlson do as well as he does
with his numbers by the way you have his
numbers because the only thing we talk
about today on the podcast was the
Friday numbers which is his last show
was
2.6 million but can you go to to to the
previous days if you haven't do you have
all of them or you don't have all so
this is the week of April 17th the week
before Tucker got fired these are the
ratings across the board so Monday night
3.174 million whereas uh CNN had yeah
000. one fifth one-fifth MSNBC at 1.4
million people then you go to Tuesday
3.22 million for Fox 750
000 for CNN 1.3 million for MSNBC
Wednesday three point uh 3 million yep
across the board you go to Thursday 2.9
Million and then Friday his final show
2.6 million people but let's fast
forward to the week that Tucker's gone
and we go to Monday God Monday you're at
2.5 first one makes sense because people
are tuning in to see who's going to be
on Tuesday 1.7 I don't like the Apple
guy Wednesday 1.3 million he's boring
Thursday it goes up a little bit 1.4
million and then Friday that they hit a
weekly low of
1.153 million people and for those of
you who think these numbers might be
fudged they're from adweek.com so these
are what people base their ad revenues
yeah by the way did you notice that even
Tucker being down Cooper went down yeah
I went down 100 000. well they didn't
move so could they didn't go up so CNN
and MSNBC didn't get more audience as a
matter of fact as Pat was just saying
Anderson Cooper went down he went down
he dropped he went from 660 730 to 580.
wow so is the argument that if they're
not on Fox and then Channel switching
maybe they're not on cable news at all
so in other words Anderson Cooper is
begging for taco to be back because it's
hurting his business during the
commercials maybe they jump over to him
the privileged son of a Vanderbilt could
be talking about cats stuck it's like
it's like CNN when Trump got transitions
when CNN people want to know yeah they
definitely want to know go ahead with
CNN like CNN is begging for Trump wait
you know how bad they want Trump to be
arguing and getting back into the races
because their ratings are going to go up
there radius went up during the whole uh
indictment thing and now they're back to
nothing so Pat here's my question to you
what do you think because Tucker's been
in this business for how long he's even
said it on the phone for a while for a
long time what what what happened in
here where I know they fired him but
something happened I think in him where
he's just like because he was speaking
out a lot lately do you think it's his
career went to cause where he's like no
I'm it's more than just the money
because he has all the money in the
world he's rich as hell say it again but
you just said he went from career to
cause like it's bigger than just the
money and the numbers and this it's his
voice he's actually that's why I respect
the hell out of him he wants to let the
people know Pat all this thing so you
make your own decision yeah you're a
musicianship you happen to Bono with you
too his career clearly went to cause a
whole red campaign and we're trying to
raise money for AIDS in Africa I think
there is a moment where you cross over
and you say you know what I'm no longer
a tool of this industry I grew up in and
remember all the wonderful nice things
that Bono had to say about the music
industry and then he was he was with the
UN and with Kofi Annan and there I think
there is a moment where you go to cause
here's what here's what you have to
think about and I'm going to give a
complete different analogy for you and
I'm going to bring Brady I'll bring Kobe
and I'll bring her three other guys okay
so think about
think about when I was in the company a
prior company I got started in that
company April of 2002 and I got in with
a dream I'm like man I'm working 80
hours a week I want to go out there and
do whatever I'm like on fire boom boom
boom and then all of a sudden I realized
the guy at the top uh we have a meeting
together with them in Hawaii and I'm
asking them questions you don't look
like you're working every time you tell
me well come to this dinner oh they
cancel last minute I'm gonna come
through this cancer cancel cancel it was
constant cancellation and winging about
what he was going to do next to help
grow the company nothing was happening
finally I confronted him and we sat down
we had to talk in Hawaii and everybody's
looking at this meeting and I said
listen man I don't believe you're doing
this anymore because you love this
business I think you're doing this just
because of money and you're done you
would much rather play golf and do other
things and I don't I want to play ball
but I need you to be straight up with me
says well you know I says I want you to
look at my eyes when you're talking to
me says well the sons of my face so I
said let's switch you sit here so we
switch Yeah I said tell me and he
eventually said you're right I don't
know what my next movies I don't know if
I love this as much as I did but so
great but I do I'm still wanting to do
this because I'm on fire about this
business great so then I leave and I go
and decide what I want to do next we
start our own company when Kobe was
playing with the Lakers who was the
owner of the Lakers when Kobe was
playing with the Lakers Jerry Buss okay
so what is the relationship of Jerry
Buss to Kobe to the GM to the head coach
what's Kobe looking for Kobe's game is
to do what what's his responsibility
improve himself improve his footwork
summertime go hang out with some uh you
know off-season go hang out with the
Rockets Elijah on see if you can do
better footwork train make sure your
health is good don't party too much
don't go crazy don't do this don't do
that
did GM's job is to do what to put people
around you to put supporting Castle
what's Jerry bus's job every year set up
the company set up the organization to
win a championship that's what you okay
no problem great so there is roles that
everybody has okay Tom Brady another guy
that played 20 some years and he played
under New England Patriots for many
years what's his head coach's job to
want to win Bill Belichick is a True
Believer he's not doing it because he
wants a paycheck Phil Jackson's not
doing it because he wants a paycheck
Philip's got how many championships he's
got 12 as a coach and one as a player
when he's got yeah he's got 12 total six
with Michael five with uh Kobe one with
the New York Knicks I think 1972 I may
be up on the years so he's got 12
championships Phil is not doing it
because he wants another house in
Montana He Does It For the Love of the
Game in history okay all right no
problem Bill Belichick Love of the Game
Tom Brady Love of the Game craft Love of
the Game let's go build the biggest
organization let's win a bunch of chips
six of them right so the thing that
changes the thing that changes when
you're at Fox no one knows if Rupert
Murdoch changed the Love of the Game
no one knows if it's all now with the
sons and the influences change because
it's you know well you know these kids
know what their time let them kind of do
this stuff and behind closers you're
like listen you're putting the wrong
leaders in in decision making process
and you're forgetting who the eyeballs
are people are coming here for us when I
was in the former company there was a
lady let's call her Susan okay
she at one point started having more
Authority than the leaders that were
built in the company and she was a home
office employee and she would say you
can't speak you can't do this and you
can't do that and she would hang up on
people I remember one time I'm like who
is this lady so when those types of
people
get more influence
and the way they talk to Talent they
forget who is King you're bound to lose
the company and you're bound to lose
people like Tucker now in this case
there's also a lady there named Susan
whatever her name is Suzanne Suzanne if
they if she thinks she's bigger than
Tucker the game is done you are not
bigger than Tucker nobody comes to Fox
to watch you people come to Fox to watch
Tucker this is the issue Michael had
with the ownership of Chicago Jerry and
Jerry well it's because of the GM if it
wasn't for us we wouldn't be able to put
the team together and Michael says what
listen I didn't see you playing tonight
we gotta still go score some points and
win the game okay and so that there was
a conflict there the point I'm trying to
make to you is we don't know the real
conflict behind closed doors on how they
view Tucker you know how annoying it is
that your name is Suzanne and everywhere
you go people say stuff like well if it
wasn't for Tucker you guys wouldn't be
number one well if it wasn't for Tucker
you wouldn't be number one well listen
how about us I mean did you see I was
ranked on media as the number one most
Power Player module yeah but if it
wasn't for tuck you wouldn't be yeah but
if it wasn't for Tucker can you imagine
how sometimes people who are non-players
their dream is to be a player they sit
there and they say what what about me
well what about me and what about me and
what about me so then this brings me to
a movie that we just watched which is
what air one of the best in a movie air
you see sunny vicaro
who is working at Nike Nike has got 17
of NBA players at the time Converse is
54 and it's Adidas that's really what
the numbers were like nobody was going
to Nike and Nike's players were the bees
Nike's players were the Beast they were
not the number one draft pick Converse
had Bird magic you know everybody Julius
Irving Adidas had everybody and so
here's here's always what we're going to
be doing what are we going to be going
after but the difference between
Converse and the difference between
Adidas was Phil Knight had a vision with
Nike
Phil Knight was at the office every day
Phil Knight wanted to build Nike who won
Michael won Sunny one fill one Nike one
everybody we all won fans one everybody
won the NBA one even the NBA collecting
fines from Nike at five thousand dollars
again for wearing red shoes day one
everybody won so in a case like this the
most important thing you have to think
about with someone like this is if I go
to sleep at night okay what things do
you not want to stress out about as a
talent you don't want to be stressed out
about what's going on at the company
you're working at of course you don't
want to go to sleep thinking what are
they going to be doing you know what are
they going to be so right now if these
guys are trying to silence a guy like
Tucker let's just say if they're saying
well you can we're not going to let them
have anybody you can't sign with anybody
we're going to pay you out we're going
to hold you in the contract if they try
to hold them hostage it's going to be a
very big thing that will backfire with
that organization you know why if they
try to hold them hostage here's what fox
needs to know City try to hold Tucker
Carlson hostage and they don't release
him from the contract great what happens
with all the talent that are looking at
going with uh Fox guess what they're
going to be thinking
dude there's the worst this is this is
that type of company I'm not going to go
into a hostage crisis type of a
situation I'm just not going to do that
if they're trying to do that I don't
know the details I made a reference of
Stefan Marbury where the team is trying
to hold the hostage if they're trying to
do that no Pat you and I follow
professional sports a lot but don't
isn't it interesting for you will also
have like a horrifying franchise and if
your agent even if they were going to
back up the truck for you your agent
comes back and says
the Seattle SuperSonics have made a big
offer and you'd be like
um it's bigger than a Laker offer yeah
but tell me about the Laker offer again
yeah because you just want to go there
yep
some organizations that just you you
wouldn't go to those organizations
well Pat you brought up a good point uh
you brought up mediaite and mediaite
actually did the most influential in
news media 2022 list this is from
December yeah but I'm gonna scroll to
the bottom I'm gonna give you the first
three and then number four is Tucker but
number one is Susan exactly I remember
this we talked about this she's number
one she's a number one power but she's
not a broadcaster she runs the network
yeah number two biggest names in media
Elon Musk not a broadcaster but he owns
Twitter but he should be number one by
the way he's a platform operator number
three Chris Licht and David this makes
sense fine not a broadcast yep the first
broadcaster that appears on the list is
number four Tucker Carlson which is
number one Talent so he is the number
one broadcaster in the United States as
far as being on television who would you
say uh who would you say is a close
number two Rogan
as far as no broadcaster in the United
States so the way I would put it I would
put separate things that's true I know
they don't combine it that way they put
everybody else the same there there is
it's two different leagues they're
playing in these are two different
leagues and what I mean by two different
leagues is two different sports Tucker
is number one in mainstream media Rogan
is number one for podcast these are two
different games and FYI you know who
else you got to put on that list Ben
Shapiro yeah Ben Shapiro when it comes
on to politics he's probably I would put
I would probably put Ben Shapiro on
politics number one for podcasting I
don't know if I put anybody on the
podcast on site above Shapiro I would
put podcasting period Rogan is obviously
the goat period politics specific it's
going to be Shapiro and then obviously
Tucker is number one from mainstream
media would you say Ben Shapiro has a
bigger reach than Anderson Cooper no way
you think Anderson Cooper has a bigger
reach than uh Ben Shapiro or no way so
independent broadcasters
established
over let's just go with Anderson Cooper
again Glenn make it here Glenn Beck I
don't I don't follow him as closely as I
do with shapir but I would say Beck at
his Peak Beck was crushing it he was a
numeral guy on TV at one point uh but
today I would say Beck is probably still
beating Anderson Cooper what Jedediah
made a great point on this morning's
podcast and if you did not happen to
watch it go back and watch it but she
talked about the death of mainstream
media and the rise of independent
broadcasters and you asked her a very
specific question about Tucker and why
there wasn't this excitement around Bill
O'Reilly why there wasn't this
excitement about Megan Kelly leaving and
she said it's the rise of the
independent broadcaster I think we're in
it this is it this is the moment where
it shifts definitively from mainstream
media and people watching it and
consuming it as the way that they've
always had to now everybody is going to
make this shift the majority of people
towards these independent broadcasters
The Blaze daily wire valuetainment Etc
good yeah I mean look the one thing you
have to know is you know when you're in
sales and you have a market or when
you're running a company and let's just
say you're you're a real estate guy or
let's just say you're an insurance guy
and 30 of your sales and your clientele
comes from a golf course that you go to
on a monthly basis where you remember at
and so you meet your clients over there
right as an insurance person and you got
another 40 that comes from you going to
I don't know I'm just making stuff up
from a local uh what do you call a chair
Chamber of Commerce meetings that you go
to another 30 as referrals that come to
you you can't all of a sudden give up
the 30 you're getting from the country
club and just go all uh uh what do you
call it Go all um
uh Chamber of Commerce his eight o'clock
is part of his audience and that's the
65 plus audience but the question
becomes is he transferable to go to the
25 to 40 year old audience does that
audience want to hear him you just saw
he went on full send podcast Their
audience says what it's a younger
podcast you saw Trump went on full sent
eight million views within 24 hours what
does it say that audience wants to hear
you exactly they want to talk to you so
the the way I would structure structure
this would be in a different way uh
because I think there's also price that
some people that want to hear what
Tucker has to say you got to pay premium
for it of course there's some stuff
that's going to be public and you're
going to distribute it everywhere
there's some stuff you want to hear this
what he has to say that's going to be
all private and you got to pay for this
there's going to be a payoff for you to
have to pay for I'll be 100 honest with
you Pat so I'm still using my
ex-girlfriend's login for Fox and
everything so I don't think well I'm
just being honest it just finished I'm
not joking it just finished it's a great
X um
this is your ex girlfriend my
ex-girlfriend imagine it's I I have her
Netflix everything the only thing that
expired was the fox thing and I it
happened two days before they let go of
Tucker
um obviously I I would have paid for it
if he still stayed there but there's
absolutely no way that I would pay for
it now if he goes somewhere else that's
Ott one thousand percent I would pay to
listen to him that that's because he's
worth it pat you feel me I pay to listen
to him and by the way let me tell you
this I would almost want him to sell to
have something on Ott where he can let
her rip and just talk and I go there and
listen to it I almost want FYI let me
let me also let me also talk to the
audience let me also talk to the
audience so audience I'm gonna talk to
you and and I kind of want you to hear
me out here and let's kind of process
this thing together okay if my argument
makes sense to you buy it if it doesn't
make sense to you don't buy it okay here
we go so some people may say well
um yeah you know I I would love for
Tucker to get a voice on blah blah blah
and I would love for that to happen hey
you know Elon Musk I would love Elon
Musk to not have to rely on big Pharma
sponsor worship and all this other stuff
hey I would love for Elon to not have to
need money from Pfizer and all these
other guys and all these companies that
are saying they're casting the
membership I would love for that to
happen hey I would love okay check this
out Netflix has 216 million users
worldwide that pin average of 12 bucks a
month let me say that one more time to
you
260 million users Netflix says that are
paying 12 bucks a month by the way I'm
helping for that and odds are you're
contributing towards that and odds are
you're contributing towards that Vinnies
you're watching this if you're watching
this if I can get your attention Tom if
you're watching this and you're saying
well I don't like the fact that Netflix
does the woke and Disney does this and
Disney does that and what no problem
then when other Otts come that are
trying to fight that and they tell you
14.99 12.99 whether it's daily wire
whether it's whatever guess what pay it
pay it because what you're doing to them
that money is going to be used to go get
Talent so this relationship is a two-way
highway I remember I would go to charity
events and I would say Jen this guy's
gonna want some money tonight get the
checkbook ready we got to cut some money
tonight okay great we're sitting there
and I'll say if the argument's good
we'll cut the check and I will sit there
and say oh my God this is such a great
point we don't need one of those
machines we need five of those machines
how much is this each machine fifty nine
thousand dollars you know what should
500 300 you know what absolutely we'll
support it we were planning on only
giving this much here's the money
because it made sense we need five of
those machines in that City instead of
just needing one machine so audience
this is a two-way Highway if you're
sitting there not happy about it you got
to fund and help those companies that
can do something with that money to get
that voice to be bigger and then this is
going to be crazier you got to go and
get that vote of other people also
subscribing just like we get somebody to
get elected so when I had Rudy Giuliani
on the podcast and we're having a
conversation on the what do you call it
the uh in 59.90 live
and he was talking about what the
election this and the election that
election this I'm like you know I'm not
for it I'm not for it says what do you
mean I'm not 40. I said here's what I'm
for if you think there's going to be any
kind of cheating going on in the
election guess what what get seven
people to go vote for vote with you
nobody should go vote by themselves what
do you mean when you go to vote do you
typically go vote by yourself yes moving
forward just like the Army we had the
buddy rule what's the buddy rule bring
somebody always have a buddy with you
Yep this year 2024 guess what you should
not elect you should not vote alone
you're going to go vote pull somebody
from the office with you hey Johnny you
want to go vote with me let's go hey you
want to go vote man let's go don't go
vote by yourself what's the point we got
to become a little bit more also you
know collectively in this tribal
leadership to say let's bring people as
well if you like like let's just say
let's say this opportunity happens and
we bring Tucker and Tucker decides to do
this okay and we have the conversation
announcements made Tucker's coming to
Valley timing fantastic guess what
whatever is going to be in a private
platform where Tucker can speak freely
and that is announced whether it's with
us or anybody else if we don't get them
I'm telling you right now anybody else
that goes gets him I'm telling you go
support it God willing it's with us
because we believe we're the right fit
but if it's not go support it and FYI
let me prep you a little bit more this
is how sometime when we started a
company this is what I said when I first
started the insurance company I said
guys I want you to be thinking about
this what's that
um we're about to make this
announcements this technology I'll never
forget bamboo when we first launch a
time you weren't there when we launched
it it was the ugliest three months of my
business career
every day we were at the office till 1
30 in the morning with customer service
live Zoom with so many different things
breaking with this and I kept telling my
guys be patient but I prepped everybody
for six months not everything's gonna go
perfectly well be patient be patient be
patient be patient boom it's crazy we
had three of our employees they used to
work here and these guys were I said
listen be patient long term we're going
to do something big they're all die hard
guys we just announced that we want to
do something with Tucker Daryl texting
me saying oh my God never thought that
was this one I said well you were
impatient if you were patient we told
you the vision is really big when Tucker
goes anywhere
and the first month two months three
months six months is not working at the
pace you want it to be be patient the
relationship is both ways that
organization's got to figure out the
Kinks and you got to figure out the
Kinks the benefit of going to a place
like Fox the benefit of going to a place
like NBC the benefit of going to a place
like CBS or maybe any of these places
guess what they have they have 600
employees that are overpaid that can go
and work on one person's project 50
people on one person's project so but if
you go to an independent organization
that is not a 12 billion dollar company
seven billion dollar company and they're
coming up they don't have those
resources yet to the level of patient
needs to be higher because the exchanges
well you go to NBC ABC mainstream your
muzzle because you can't talk about
everything because your biggest sponsor
is Pfizer over here you are not muzzles
you can talk about everything but you
don't have the 600 employees and you got
to be kind of patient for this thing to
develop but if the relationship with the
users and the customers and the
capitalist the entrepreneur the town
Talent is honest and sincere long term
we're going to win this what fight but
it's not going to be just the talent in
the company and not the involvement of
the talent the what do you call it the
fans and the audience getting involved
as well this is going to take a real
teamwork effort the next three five ten
twenty years for us to win this fight
and by the way if there's ever been a
fight worth fighting this is it I was
looking at a book upstairs shown to uh
seven of our Executives about 10 year
olds what book they're getting on
Section on sex education I'm showing
this clip and and and the book is sold
Millions on top of millions of copies in
public schools they're shown positions
on how two boys can have sex in school
yeah two girls can have sex in school
then you have the mission missionary
which is a boy and a girl which is you
know it's a regular
a ten-year-old guy a 10 year old boy is
going to learn how to have sex with
another boy listen if there's ever been
a time that is going to take everyone's
effort we're just sitting around
bitching and complaining about it it's
not going to mean anything you got to
get involved you got to support if you
support a brand if it's not us go
support somebody or support them if it's
us support us collectively 10 20 years
from then we're going to look back and
say we did this together it's not going
to be a one-man show it's not going to
be a one-team show it's going to be
Collective effort with you and us doing
it together without you there is no
entertainment without you there's no PPD
podcast without you we don't have this
Media Company without you you and I
don't meet each other without you we
don't have all these people that are
working here this has been Collective
I'm grateful for you guys but I just
want to prep you and I hope this kind of
made sense to some of you guys that are
still watching this I'm gonna ask you
for more if you say Pat we're going to
do this we kind of need to get to the
next phase of we're gonna need your help
at the next level you know till today
I'll tell you one thing about valetama
um Tom when we were building the
insurance company you know my salary not
when we sold the company but you know my
salary when we build an insurance
company was I ever the highest paid guy
in the company
absolutely not you were not even in the
top ten what was I paying myself salary
was you you know you were part of the
payroll
can you tell everybody what I was making
barely 100 Grand and and by the way a
lot of that was benefits because you got
the medical package for your family
eventually my salary went up to 250.
okay salary and then if the company did
well I got something of the ebitda five
percent of whatever the ebitda was about
five million dollars of you better so
it's not like it's millions of dollars
I'm getting another hundred thousand
dollars two hundred thousand dollars
three hundred thousand dollars a bonus
but it was based on growing the company
I didn't have any problem till today
from value payment day one till today
you know how much money I've taken off
the table for my payment zero I don't
take a salary from this I don't take
profits at the end of the year
everything's reinvested into the item
because vision is real so when we're
doing what we're doing I was like oh my
God I can't believe we have to pay that
I can't believe we're we're not doing
this because I'm trying to go buy
another car I've made a good decision
I've done well for myself financially
where we've set aside a good amount of
money and we sold the insurance company
this is a project of 40 years I'm going
40 years with media with vitamin period
And I say this a long time ago and I'm
saying it right now I don't need another
exit to become financially free we are
going on a 40-year run God willing we're
healthy I'm 44 if I live up to 84. thank
you God I've already lived an incredible
life the things I've done I'm very happy
about it but the next 40 years God
willing uh will be able to compete in
the marketplace and with guys like
Tucker once in a lifetime type of a guy
you know you'll like the guy you want to
hear more the guy you want to hear his
perspective you want to hear what
questions he's asking in the way he goes
and researches the way he interviews
people you know his Charisma his
authenticity there's a lot of people
that want to see this guy run there's
people that are talking about why does
not just announce and go wrong for
president why don't you just go and run
for office he may even just announce
that I'm gonna go around for office you
know what would happen what a shakeuper
would be if we made that kind of
announcement but what's the point the
point is people are saying that because
they would like a guy like this to run
the country yeah if he chooses to do
that great if he chooses to join a
platform like car is great if we're here
oh my God all I can tell you his future
looks bright
no matter where he goes and we're going
to support the guys I hope I hope the
people and thank you everybody that that
is supporting valuetainment thank you
Pat Uh I just have to say that off the
rip but uh uh I I first of all I don't
think he should like 100 do not do
anything political pack because you saw
what they did with Trump they're going
to 100 go after him as well what do you
think Tom if he goes for if he did
anything political what would happen to
him
Tucker Tucker
Tucker's gonna make more of a difference
and be more of a candidate than anybody
realizes he could be he could be
tremendous but I think his voice his
talents look you know you look at who is
Tucker I look at him he's an
entrepreneur he created Daily Caller
he's a producer he has an eye for
content
he's a voice and a personality of his
own show he's also an author if you ever
ever read Ship of Fools you should read
Ship of Fools it's a great book kind of
funny too
you step back and look at that you know
why we you know why I recognize all that
because we're all that I mean look at
Pat Pat's multi-time entrepreneur he's
an author he's a producer my gosh and
he's a yeah and he's his own voice and
personality we understand that and we
are that and so I look at all that and I
kind of see I said wow you know Tucker
is very much like us could he be very
well in political sphere absolutely but
I think he still has a voice an
opportunity and he could take his time
and talents and really you know Drive in
Service to America what we're talking
about can I tell you selfishly where I'm
at let me tell you something for sure
well man okay as a as a guy who wants to
run with this guy we'd love for him to
be here but I'm telling you if he ran
I'm 100 supported behind him because I
think he would be the number two guy
overnight I agree with the number two
guy overnight I'd be right with you and
that's for my trip today number two guy
overnight so purely support uh I said
this to Megan earlier Megan's like so
what do you think about the fact that
the video just came out and the fact
that he said this and he said that in
this video that was released and leaked
by you know Fox and what are your
thoughts about this you know what my
answer was I said listen you know what
history tells us
people who had the audacity to fight a
fight against the bullies and Bully the
bully were never perfect
they were not the people that you saw
them you're like oh my God what a you
know a fantastic this now
Churchill
was able to do something Chamberlain
couldn't do okay it's just period
Ulysses says Grand was able to do
something McClellan who was all he
wanted to do was train train train train
train train train train train train for
a you know uh for Abraham Lincoln all he
wanted to do was train constantly train
the soldiers listen Lincoln's like
listen how many more months do you need
to train your guys let's roll no they're
not fully trained yet dude we gotta go
to war we gotta win this war no they're
not trained yet
Ulysses has Grant I keep trying to get a
hold of him he's not he's not I can't
get a hold of him
Lincoln is furious because he can't hear
hear back from Ulysses S Grant when he
hears from guess what he says we won
guess what ulyssa says Grant was
drunk all this other stuff what happens
to Grant after Lincoln dies two-term
president yeah okay so so the point is
we can go back and talk about
how you know so much of well you what
about this and what about that and what
about this listen yeah we're looking for
somebody who's a dog of a fighter when I
say dog I mean a dog fight this guy's
got the dog fight in him uh you you know
when's the first time I fell on with the
scum I'm like I freaking like this guy
was when Jon Stewart came in to try to
bully him and I watched him yeah how
many times I watched it you only tell
you how many times I watched a club you
know how many times I washed up a couple
of times if I tell you 200 times that's
a low number really do like for me in
basketball I watch more post game
interviews than I watch interview then I
watch the game I'm a post-game interview
guy I watched the other day John Morant
you lost what's your comment so hey John
what do you have to say about the fact
that I don't think about anybody in the
west he said I have to deal with that
you know it is what it is you have weak
answer hey uh Giannis uh what do you do
you consider this year a failure
Eric
you asked me the same question last year
okay
when Stewart came in
and he was a main guy and he tried to
bully him you just watch Tucker
and I'm telling you Tucker never forgot
that and as much as John peaked
Tucker took it all the whole different
level it was a way of saying look man
I'm not going to get bullied
it's very hard to find people like
Tucker
I don't I don't we've never had dinner
together before we've never broken bread
I'm not sitting here saying we're
friends oh you know it's my body nope
I've never said that and I'm not here to
say that because we've never had any
kind of up onto this conversation taking
we've never had anything that has ever
happened right
when I see a guy like that that's that
video took place with John trying to
make you guys just you got to stop
you're terrible you're this and he sees
reaction yeah well you know and then all
of a sudden he see him going from the
bow tie yeah I hear saying you know
under shadow of all the people and then
boom he's at the top listen I relate to
Underdogs that guy was an underdog now
he's at the top and he's got a good I
think he's got a good 10 to 15 year run
of being on fire and his voice is needed
every night people are asking where's
this guy's voice so anyways look we
wanted to do this uh live podcast uh
simply because there's a lot of
questions that's being asked if you want
to find out more about the story Rob if
you can put the link below for people to
go find it uh you can see the clip as
well with me and Megan Kelly I actually
really like the conversation we had when
Megan Kelly today her show man she's
rocking she just crossed a million Subs
she's doing she's doing congratulations
big milestone she's always been she's
always been one of the greatest to ever
do it but Megan seems to be like right
now it's like you you're like hey she's
like everywhere now back at it like what
she wants you know so she has fire I'm
excited to see I hope she becomes one of
the moderators for you know the election
because she was very good when she was
out there asking the questions anyways
if you want to see that put the link
below as well the link to the article
and the offers that we made you can find
it on Twitter all over the place gang uh
if you are still here with us smash that
subscribe button we love you we
appreciate you we couldn't do this
without you take care everybody bye-bye
bye-bye